millionen machen und dann hätte einfach
gehen ich weiß nicht auf contis
verantwortung ok abstürzt ich habe jetzt
an wieder erfolg ich auch darum bat wir
sterben
ich habe nichts zu fressen hier jetzt
auch nicht ich sterbe in sehr gut
hallöchen freunde und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu captain micro in
der letzten folge
das anhängerschaft geschlossen oder
umgebaut ein portal gebaut ist
wunderschön und auch in dieser folge
wollen wir einige sachen schafft und
zwei begebe ich mich auf die suche nach
travel habe ich mir sofort genommen
damit wir das kein portal anzünden
können und was kann ich denn noch machen
was wir machen könntest vielleicht hier
um die farben weiter ausbauen
die höhle weiter nach unten graben
werden ja alles möglich aber so viel
eisen ich mal jetzt erst mal eine sache
nicht dass so lange drauf gewartet und
wir haben auch wieder ein thema und zwar
wird mir die kommentare geschrieben was
wir denn davon halten oder was wir denn
vorher vor der wm gedacht haben was sie
jetzt denken über hat die leistung von
deutschland und zwar ich fange jetzt mal
ganz vielleicht anwalt in der letzten
folge mit dem englisch thema der
grundschule angefangen hast genau ich
hab echt von anfang an gedacht so wie es
bei jeder wm denke wenn ich mir diese
testspiele angucke mensch hat wird doch
nichts da zeige ich mir bei jeder wm
weil deutschland ist eine
turniermannschaft zuvor den ich weiß
noch damals 2006 haben sie kurz vor der
wm noch 41 irgendwie gegen usa verloren
und haben trotzdem bei der wm noch den
dritten platz gemacht und alles mögliche
und auch bei dieser wm wie sie sich
schwer getan haben gegen die
gruppengegner und in den testspielen
auch und da wieder 0 0 gespielt gegen
santander dort also das war alles nicht
so wie man sich das gewünscht hätte
allerdings letztendlich muss ich sagen
hat deutschland bewiesen wieder dass die
nationalmannschaft sind und das ganze
reißen können und ich find's einfach nur
extrem geil dass die so weit gekommen
sind die schöne finale und ich mal man
sagt zwar jedes jahr so herkommen wenn
nicht jetzt wann dann aber ohne spaß
wenn jetzt schon so krass drauf sind und
brasilien 72 herauspicken
dann musst du eigentlich diese ja was
werden vor allem wenn man sich das spiel
holland gegen argentinien angeguckt hat
er das wahre langeweile weil keiner von
beiden ins finale wollte gegen
deutschland als richtig gemerkt soll
deswegen ich würde sagen ich habe auf
jeden fall auf keinen fall gedacht dass
deutschland so krass weit kommt vor
allem weil wir so ein junges team haben
uns unerfahrene leute also
da muss ich einspruch einlegen es gibt
ja schon viele bei uns im team so im
vergleich zu den anderen gegner teams
die schon wirklich lange und viele
wermes mitgemacht haben zum beispiel
klose
er will ja auch schon oft dabei sein
schweinsteiger das total andere position
mittlerweile ja die andere schule
gespielt wurde auch auf defensive
mittelfeld umgeschult und auf den
position sind sie komplett neu im
internationalen vergleich natürlich die
erfahrung haben sie aber wenn ich da so
sollen julian draxler zahlen die bühne
gebracht dann auch schön und so diese
noch relativ jung aber nicht schlau
schlau gemacht von löw auf jeden fall
dass man jemals finde ich auch in die
wir am rhein bringt den mal so das
feeling gibt okay so fühlt sich das an
da will man das spielt vorsorge für
millionen menschen
und man das dann auch nicht in anger ein
spiel macht wo sag ich mal das dann
entscheidend wäre entscheidende spiel wo
ist dann meinetwegen 11 steht und er
dann solche jungspunde dahin lässt das
war ja auch nicht gerade optimal ich
finde dass er besser wenn man so wie bei
dem spiel gegen brasilien halt macht ja
ich find's gut dass löw auf jeden fall
den leuten die chance gibt und es
meinten auch viele bei dem spiel gegen
brasilien
ich finde gar kein griffel also das
meint nicht die leute erinnern dass
keine milch nichts ein die gc überhaupt
mit uns dann einfach weiter runter bauen
okay ich brauche mal wie ein knochen
denke es wäre so toll ich bin gleich
anfangen also ich glaube ich werde
dieses folge noch sterben nur wegen
hunger
du kannst du jetzt glätte treffen jawohl
sind welche wasser und in alle irgendwo
bestimmt wir haben alles ausgerichtet
fläche sogar eine blöde entscheidung ja
ja ich weiß nicht ja ich fand zum
beispiel paar leute haben gemeint
brasilien 721 rauszuwerfen das doch
total fies und alles finde ich nicht
weil sowie die basilius brasilianischen
fans das deutsche team ausgepfiffen
haben
ich weiß doch bei der wm 2006 in
deutschland da wurden die gegner
wirklich mit respekt begrüßt da wurde
auf jeden fall nicht 10 minuten forster
gegen ein team gemacht aus gar keinen
grund und die brasilianischen fans die
sind ja mal so intolerant ii die pfeife
einfach ihren stürmer fred aus weil er
keine chancen reinmacht also preise
nicht dass die da nicht sagen sie ja
kaum jungs haben super gespielt mein
brasilien war gut und hat auch keiner
gedacht dass die wirklich auch so weit
kommen mit seinem jungen team aber
das achte bist da unten genau hier soll
nach dem willen aber ich bin schaffen
bedrock angekommen redstone dafür und
was nicht er weiß nicht als ich hat zum
beispiel nie gedacht dass deutschland so
weit kommt ich hätte ehrlich gesagt noch
nicht es geht nur ist als layout
jemanden auf der messe jedes mädel hat
es gibt drei jahren auf der map 5
gefunden also keine ahnung
okay okay einen diamanten bekommen er
ist hier nicht mehr aber trotzdem aber
dass die diamanten erstmal sparen weil
wir können uns einen zauber tisch machen
echt ja-stimmen erfolge ja den kann ich
machen wenn er ein buch dafür brauchen
wir zucker worden da kommen wir ja bald
in wir brauchen noch ein paar erfolge
und dann sind wir auch schon dabei dem
wasser braucht zur karosse wollen wir
das ganze haus holen oder wollen wir uns
vielleicht auch gleich mal einfach nach
oben weiter bauen weil oben waren ja
auch noch ein paar sachen weil erst noch
weisen dass er sehr schwer jeden fall
schaue ich gehe mal eben wir hier nach
also ich baue ich mal nach oben
obwohl die diamanten erstmal sparen
genau erstmal die online ich bin beiden
silberfischchen was hattest du denn
überhaupt bei deutschland gedacht ach
komm mit diamanten nein ehrlich es gibt
nur drei diamanten hier auf der karte
es gibt nur drei ich glaube wir alle
drei schon gefunden kontrast aggressiv
manchmal bekommen sechs diamanten
gefunden
sehr stark ist doch ein gerade gefunden
aber das weiter sechs krass ist es ein
neues dungeons ist das alte oder dass
man einfach alles abbauen bis auf
patrick baum nicht die blöcke april
aber ich möchte rhein gucken ob das
jetzt ein neues dungeon ist pass auf da
ist schon wieder so ein silbrig weiß ich
möchte töten die halt ich hasse die soll
jedoch kommen an stern bald allem eine
aua soll jedoch kommt ok
4,9 aber treibt wieder du arsch man se
ich habe nichts zu fressen hier ich auch
nicht ich sterbe in sehr gut aber jetzt
ist das problem mit dem hunger mal bei
mir gelöst ich komm mal wieder runter
ganz geschmeidig ich sterbe ich habe
aber nichts von ihr auf gesammelt doch
eine axt und tischen kohle aber hier ist
alles frisch schmeckt wie ganz daneben
hat er gesagt ich werde bald ich bin
bald durch den hunger und dann also das
so tot bist ja wenn ich schon sagen ich
bin fast tot dann bin ich immer mit so
kann das ist ja auch die rache dafür
wenn er die auch nicht böse ich habe
übrigens gefunden decken die ganze zeit
änderte silberfisch dahin und dann die
größte sache überhaupt ich werde von den
fischen attackiert schwimmen im fluss
schwimmen in der lava und er macht mir
nicht die tür auf der also dass jetzt
alles nicht aufgewacht und hab ja sich
aufgebaut hat zu gemacht
also das war echt schon bisher konnten
kommen mittelfinger hoch muss schon
lachen also sind cool ich nicht so hat
jetzt mal ein feuerzeug und sind dann
länder portal an oder auf der weißen zu
hoch oder zu
erst mal besser aber ich bin voll herren
er fest dass man besser an ich weiß
nicht ob sie das irgendwie musst wenn du
das gebaut hat stimmt ihn immer voll ja
okay ich bin auf meinem weg hoch erst
mal kurz aus fressen nach oben also ja
das hat noch gedacht das ist ja mal soll
es regnen
nein
der perfekte zeitpunkt also für den
ändert portal
das alter der mädchen in der kiste
das sieht man nur wenn man die kiste
aufmacht rechnet man die mittlere kiste
auf
ich habe da kein münchen bei mir in der
mittleren spur obwohl über sei es erst
mal ganz gemeine sachen jahr ein mann
auch heute gestern sah hier kommt hier
russells arbeit worten gib mir schnell
den feuerstein anbau ich dass ich hatte
schon ab nach oben ich mir das vor dem
portal heller dann können wir bunga
bunga machen das machen wir dann einfach
vom portal sich aus schönwald kein regen
sein späteres opfer gibt da noch gar
nicht ausgeleuchtet richtig gelaufen
okay er machte sie okay ich mache es du
bist du bereit für den bunga bunga tanz
ja wirklich
nein weil ich erwarte dann ist
eigentlich sein dass du die ganzen das
für die ganze erfolg noch gar nicht hast
doch und dass ich das eigentlich machen
muss ja das wird nichts machen da könnte
man es noch löschen und wir warten mal
gibt es dafür überhaupt ein erfolg dauer
ein portal zum netter wir müssen noch
tiefer genau und diamanten habe ich
geschafft der bommeraner nicht nicht
nicht richtig kommt da raus gehen raus
und es wird auch geraten wenn wir einmal
besser waren dann müssen wir nach jedem
tief mit den server neu starten ja da
bin ich mir nicht sicher ob das so toll
war weiß nicht gehabt es war kein traum
also das ist ja mal täglich wie hell ich
bin uns wird geraten von early boy dass
wir nach jedem tief mit den server neu
starten sollen wenn wir im jänner waren
da bin ich mir schreibt es war bitte in
die kommentare weil ich bin mir da nicht
sicher
da kommt dann wieder ja ich es gibt nur
drei diamanten auf der ganzen karte ihr
müsst alle zwei minuten in server neu
starten weil es gibt nur richtig schief
und das meine ich bekommt man solche
kommentare iolo machen und dann hätte
einfach gehen ich weiß nicht ob comics
verantwortung ok server abstürzt
ich habe jetzt ein erfolg ich auch darum
beim sterben
was war das denn bitte ich bin hier oben
aber jetzt gab es praktisch nein da ist
gast in unserer welt
ich hab wird es brutal aus geschossen
ich glaube da hat unser portal
ausgeschossen gas komme ja ja ja
wie sollen wir jetzt an uns rankommen
wir rein und schön wie roh zu essen
ich gehe rein in die hölle machte also
ich verknüpfe bau was haut wenn ich
weiter hatte wohl recht
ich sterbe er direkt wieder ohne wird
der dienst alle items ein mann stirbt
direct wer weiß denn das könnten server
resort machen
aber was soll denn das
das kann doch nicht sein oder
konstanz auch merklich gesagt ich kann
das denn sein dass man in never geht
ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht mit
sportliche
wie kann das denn sein das verstehe ich
hab man gerade gar nicht geladen wird
dann bleiben die da glaube ich liegen
aber also wenn wir einen server
verlassen
wir haben wolf gar nicht guten ja das
wollte ich zu dir sagen dachte ich auch
gerne lieber nicht hören was macht jetzt
wie die einigung sieht auch vor ihre
mutter aber ja das wettbieten erwarten
was aber wenn das nicht gewollt ist von
meiner branche das kann doch nicht sein
dass man im bett geht
da sind jetzt alle unsere guten sachen
du weißt schon dass wenn wir sie jetzt
nicht retten
denn eventuell bald weg sind ja aber du
hast doch die diamant in die kiste
gepackt
nee verein gebunden
du hast deine diamanten mittel den
netter genommen einen diamanten anja
mathis mehr als kaida
nein wir hatten deswegen ist die
diamanten spitzer kann ich dabei wir
müssen auch nur einmal den server neu
starten glaube ich und dann können wir
darauf wären und die sachen retten ja
dann starrt man neu ich kann ihn nicht
durchstarten
du bist der opa für europa weggenommen
dafür kann ich den server nicht nur
schweiß riechst oder nein
speed drauf man mag ich kann / talk
probieren aber ich glaube nicht dass so
haben wir neue hochwasserprobleme alles
was du kannst es jetzt geklappt server
klar
das war's dann wird der projekt wir
hoffen es hat ja die folge sehr zu
ändern wir beenden an der stelle
wir müssen wir schauen wie wir
weitermachen mal ob das käme kaum
vorstellen dass das an wie gewollt ist
vom web erstellen und das kann ja nicht
sein das kann nicht sein
ich finde den server auch gar nicht mehr
lustig algier
ich habe aber ich kann auch nicht drauf
okay doch doch es geht schnell anmelden
okay ich bin drauf ich sagen das
probieren in der nächsten folge bei
komme
naja meinst du wenn ich auch kurz bei
dirschauer konrad durch den jetzt durch
mal hoch ich komme ja ich mag einfach
mal alle meine sachen in die kiste bitte
bitte bitte lass es klappt haben
wünschen auf mac nach oben
ich fand einfach herunter hab ich
gesehen und einen füße rojo berichten
gleich ernst das kann doch nicht sein
kann das denn sein du hast gesagt
ob das wohl ein troll ist ärgerlich sei
sicher drin
ich hab mir das altenstadt rausgeworfen
immer das also später siegte ausgehen
dass geht es geht
da müssen wir echte maßstab machen alle
sachen ja beim hasen heruntergefallene
und ich hab keinen bock jetzt unten was
hast du alles hast du den diamant ich
hab den die diakonie diamanten jammern
aber sehr gut aber noch mal vielen dank
an der stelle an early boy oben ist eine
truhe dass er uns sehr dass verraten hat
der gedanke dann lange gebraucht wird
herausfinden
ich würde einfach sagen freunde damit
beenden wir euch nach schönstatt wieder
da wenn wir diese folge gefallen hat
diese der chaotische folge helfer kann
sein mag ich da und wir in den letzten
folgen wieder bei komme ein schild ö